welcome to this video this is the fourth
part and final part about the London
system is black how to battle this kind
of setup with Bishop f4 d4 Knight f3
Bishop f4 and in the first three videos
I had a look at setups with the g5 setup
with Knight f6 and ecigs
all night f6 and g6 yeah this is
basically all the mainline setup that
black can play but I thought I made a
quick video I'll make a quick video
about if white ghost Bishop f4 against
against the rarer moves in fact um one
of the advantages of some of those rare
removes is that the London system uses
some lots of lots of power actually so
let's have a look at g6 which leads to
the same as g6 in this case so I'm this
early fianchetto hoon I have three
different to g7 and we should have a
form what makes the usual system moves
and like placed e6 this also shows that
it's simple transposition compared to 1
d6 so no black would start like this for
example we have the same position um in
fact this kind of setup is rather weak
for white when the London is not the
most threatening opening anyway but here
a black gum achieves a very easy game
and this is because in this setup he
will get to play e5 without any kinds of
problems the night on g8 is still at
home and E 5 therefore it's easy to to
play and yeah this is some helpful for
black in a position where the knight is
already on f65 would be more difficult
in my suggested set
I actually suggested to plane that F to
d7 so you could if you want just as
opposed to what I recommended in video 2
and then e5 but okay see you need two
moves and then play e5 yeah and in the
g6 move order you can just do this
immediately yeah here white most often
plays each edge free because the five he
wants to go all the way back to h2 and
here black has a choice even he can play
more than one good setup you can even
think about playing f5 immediately but I
like the move Queen e7 first it
strengthens them a five point and keeps
you flexible you can continue with f5
anyway so let's say we should be two and
then you can go f5 or not h6 first let's
say I have five castles and then Knight
h6 this is a possible setup the e5 pawn
is nicely protected by those pieces the
knight on H sticks will go to f7 so
let's let's just put it on the board
before example something like this it's
very comfortable for black c6 is
designed to keep d5 under control so
black would play Knight f7 and would
have a very nice flexible structure he
was able to play F v e5 and has a good
foothold in the center so black is is
fine
you can also mix some move orders here
you can start start out with f5 this
might attempt to why to play something
like this I don't know if I want this is
black queer e7 first is probably more
solid but you could if you want also
play stuff like 97 on night to h6 which
might be an idea if white would wouldn't
play h3 so let's say here what would
play Bishop b2 then e 5 Knight 9070
could be a good idea or not h6 the idea
being to
get to f5 so let's n97 and if Whitewood
Castle now then Knight f5 would will net
black the the bishop pair this is why
white usually in this position place h3
- oops I mean in this position plays h3
to secure this spot on h2 where the
bishop cannot be exchanged easily yeah
in fact it is a good idea if you are if
you intend the Kings Indian setup and
you know that your opponent is going to
play a Bishop f4 system a London system
it is really a good idea to gamble a bit
and play maybe this move oops not H to
start with g6 and Battle of the London
the way I just I just showed the only
drawback is that if white of course
plays before on move to so if you don't
know what to do then it's it's a bit of
a risk to play this way but there are
some players that who really always play
this setup with Bishop f4 and against
those players I would recommend this
because it's it's simply it's simply a
great setup where black has no problems
at all it's very very nice yeah if you
play d6o g6 really doesn't matter much
it's it's all the same um what other
moves are there um e six is a possible
first move of course if white then opts
for the London then I mean probably
immediately then you can play em very
much like Knight f6 six lines and just
go Knight f6 and continue with c5 it's
quite the same as shown in video three
of the sum of this series so it's not
much of a difference if you want to go
for a Dutch setup and you can do it it's
not not bad and bad really
this kind of this kind of setup is
possible then on ideas to play with v6
or Bishop d6 with between looking word
it's not a bad idea but let's say b6
this is this is perfectly playable for
black you only need to be cautious that
white doesn't get to play you fall under
favourable circumstances so um you can
you must at the right time put some
piece on you four sometimes even Bishop
before us an idea it looks maybe we had
in first sight but it's not bad so it's
not not a big problem here we should
have formed against against T six I mean
we have some choice how to how to to
battle this yeah what other moves are
there I mean we have the the Dutch
defense some players like to play lamb
Bishop f4 against the Dutch and it's
probably on move to that it's most
dangerous it's less dangerous if white
plays in this fashion and we will see
why here I would say 9 f6 fits into any
system 6 any another question is what
you want to do you can play a six year
if you play a Dutch with d6 then
probably this is the move to go and you
would get pretty much the same position
that I described before with those ideas
to put a piece on you for this is
certainly alright what you need to be
cautious with as some if you play a
Leningrad type of setup with the g6 then
why did this position has got the
somewhat route looking but not at all
armless move h4 and okay this is a very
aggressive move from for someone who's
playing Bishop f4 but this is a very
specific type of Bishop f4 against f5
and if black isn't careful white can
easily get a super strong attack here
I just show something let's say Bishop
g7 h5 night h5 and you just sex exchange
here just just to put it on the board
you'll see instantly that black is in
huge trouble cut down all kinds of
attacking moves coming and you really
don't want that the computer even now
yes this is lost would like already it's
simply not playable so you need to be
cautious this is really dangerous so
what the black can play as some oops
here you probably need to anticipate
this move and one possibility is the
move h6 cm2 on h5 to be able to play g5
and you don't have the problem of course
this is a bit weakening but ok you're
playing the Dutch defensive here if you
play the Dutch you you should be used to
have a wicking site it's nothing nothing
out of the ordinary and let's say Knight
c3 and now blacks ideas to play d6 and
prepare a 5 in the long run sometimes
you can even play ecigs Queen e7 and
then e 5 so this is a tricky position um
which um I don't know I like white a bit
here but okay that's the Dutch Jam
it's always a bit double-edged and hard
to hard to assess um what I'm getting at
is if you play the Dutch and someone
plays Bishop f4 against you to sage for
thing it's a bit tricky you need to have
somebody I think what I would I put on
the board it's not bad with u6 but it's
still the tricky setup in comparison um
this 963 this e 6 stuff and b6 is easier
to play after King Cyrus not so weak I
don't know maybe something to consider
even if you usually play the landing
Retton this might be an idea if White
has played an early night
three like this here and then this move
then g6 is of course less of an issue
because h4 h5 is probably not so
dangerous so this one and then I know to
start Bishop g7 or d6 this is not so
dangerous in comparison because you
don't have the the immediate exchange
saikhan h5 with the Queen taking so on
should be a should be fine for black
Bishop f4 it's not so bad against the
Dutch really it's a bit a bit of an
underestimated um move probably but you
need to play this h4 stuff if you don't
do this and play passively it can easily
be be not not great for white so if you
if you look at this white playing
passively and it just just to show what
is happening if if white would play
really nothing kind of moves 8 386
castles then you can set up something
like this
c6 reform queen here and then Knight to
c6 and c5 or 937 and 85 and we get a
position which is a bit similar to the
position that I showed after one g6 is
just that black probably loses a move
and the process I see place is sixty
five and two moves but it's still a good
setup if you get this pawn do we 5 + f5
you you're very rarely worse of course
if you explode something on the Queen
side that it can be but usually if you
are able to play this here you should be
fine as if good sessions you have a good
center center simply so this is really
not not dangerous some if you know what
you're doing and the white plays
passively H force another story after g6
yeah what other moves are there we are
almost through with all of them
c5 maybe some sometimes
the Bologna is played if white wants to
go into a London then he probably
probably will answer C 3 and here I'm
yeah here it's a bit tricky what what
should black play if you want to play
play ecigs in fact trying to transpose
until the lines I am shown in the first
video the the third video actually in
the series then white has one e form and
you can transpose to a french all of a
sudden and not sure if you would want
that so need to be cautious with these
six you also need to be cautious with a
move like d5 as taking as some is really
an option it's simply a Slav with an
extra tempo and probably you won't get
the pawn back so on a bit of bit of
caution advised yeah you can also not
really covered c5 this kind of move just
gets on this would be for and this is a
really good good position for white
transposing it to assist free Sicilian
but in a really passive form so I yeah
what should like do probably the
healthiest move is to take on deform but
this is a bit down you can do this and
transpose to the Slav exchange yeah as
mentioned it is a dollar bit yeah so so
what a lot should you do exactly um you
could play Knight f6 yeah but you need
to take into account that like that
white might might take this is important
and tries to keep the pawn but probably
here it's too early to take six will get
the pawn back so ninety f6 is the most
flexible move which after ninety f3 um
Canada took positions that I discussed
further early and the third video or I
like the move Queen c7 TM this is also a
good move
covering the porn preventing Bishop f4
with it in very straightforward fashion
and black free pass both feared shadows
and this is brother flexible for black I
like this so this also represents my
recommendation in this move order white
place this I would go Queen c7 of course
is six is a transposition after you
should refer to the third video but I
think black should grab the chance to
play Queen c7 because it's a very nice
dynamic move it prevents this Bishop f4
canvas of the pawn so white cannot
really snatch this pawn and you are
really planning to set up your pieces
through your bishops in the most
flexible and aggressive way on the long
diagonal so this looks like like a fine
fine setup in general um the London
loses lots of is appeal against the
lines I showed this video against g6 I
think it's also not too too dangerous I
think there's exactly one scenario where
the London system is a really really
promising opening and this is where when
black has played in early six or let's
say in this position would play six it's
not terrible but he needs to really know
what what he's doing it can easily
backfire on black he plays two passively
like this Bishop e7 should be three
castles ninety five and this can easily
lead to a nice attacking position with
with white so I'm black shouldn't play
passively the the lines I showed with d5
all involved not playing e6 and killing
your bishop for some time but play
Bishop f5 at some point and the e6 lines
had this fianchetto so
this is what what I'm talking about at
this fianchetto so black always has
healthy pieces and and a rather good
game yeah I hope those four videos will
help you to to to battle this opening
it's not of course the most exciting and
threatening opening but it's good to
know at least some decent set up which
make sure that you get a fine position
and have a chance to outplay the
opponent so that it's some fight left on
the board of course it's rather tedious
at times but there's not much you can do
this is rock solid you cannot storm this
kind of opening quickly it's simply not
possible so take a look at them the
videos to get some some get some idea
what good setups are available for black
yeah thanks for watching I'll be back
soon